التطرف اليمني سيكون عنوانا لحكومه
السادسه الامر الذي يثير قلق دوائر امنيه
وسياسيه في اسرائيل تحذر من ان استجابه
لتنياهو لطلب المتطرف لتمر بن جرير
الميدان بالانتماء لتنظيم داخل الارهابي
بان يتسلم حقيبه الامن الداخلي وان يصبح
مسؤولا عن الشرطه في ظل خطته المعلنه
لسماح لليهود بالصلاه في ساحات المسجد
الاقصى ستفجر حربا مع قطاع غزه وتصعيدا
على جانبي الخط الاخضر الى جانب ازمه
دبلوماسيه مع الاردن ودول الاخرى
فاننا نتنياهو سيحاول احتواء التابعات لان
ذلك لا يمكن ان يؤدي الى ازمه علاقات مع
الاردن ومصر والدول العربيه
ينتمون للتيارات الدينيه المتطرفه
وينصعون للحفمات لا القوانين الاسرائيليه
بين ان هناك اجماعا لدى احزاب التكتل
اليمني على تمرير ما يسمى قانون التغليب
اي تغليب قرارات السياسيين على قرارات
القضاء الى جانب تشريعات من شانها ان تلغي
بعضا من الاتهامات بالفساد الموجهه
لنيتنياهو من سيحدد وجه التكتل اليمني هو
حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه واشخاص مثل بنفيرتش
والمتدينون ما سيجعل الائتلاف على يمين
اليهود ويدفع لكود نحو التشدد اليمني اكثر
ما سيؤثر على العلاقه مع العرب على صعيد
العلاقات الدوليه والاقليميه فان وجوده
ورثه كهانه وفكره ترحيل الفلسطينيين
وتسويق قتلهم يشكل عقبه امام نيته حيث
اوضح الامريكيون واشنطن لن تتعاطى مع
وزراء متطرفين وكذا تلقت اسرائيل تحذيرا
من الاردن والامارات ودول الاخرى
في اسرائيل بان حجم
تتغير مع المنصب الرسميه كما حدث لشارون
حين انسحب من غزه بين ان حكومتان يبدو
فيها نتنياهول اكثر اعتدال قد تغلبها
تركيباتها المتطرفه بما لها من تبعات
خطيره سياسيه وامنيه زياد حلبي العربيه
القدس الغربيه